>> Laura: WE WON'T BE FOOLED
AGAIN.
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
THEN THERE WAS A LOT OF
SPECULATION SWIRLING AMONG MEDIA
TYPES AND POLITICAL JUNKIES
ABOUT WHY JOE BIDEN DIDN'T
DELIVER A LIVE ADDRESS AT ONE OF
THE 9/11 MEMORIAL SITES ON
SATURDAY'S ANNIVERSARY.
CONSERVATIVES SAID IT WAS
BECAUSE BIDEN'S HANDLERS WORRIED
THAT HE WOULD EMBARRASS HIMSELF
AND LIBERALS BLAMES IT ON THE
POSSIBILITY THAT BIDEN ACTUALLY
MIGHT BE BOOED WHILE SPEAKING.
THEY DIDN'T WANT TO HAVE THAT.
BUT I HAVE ANOTHER THEORY THAT'S
JUST AS PLAUSIBLE.
WHY WOULD BIDEN NEED TO SPEAK AT
ALL WHEN GEORGE W. BUSH WOULD DO
IT FOR HIM.
>> WE HAVE SEEN GROWING EVIDENCE
THAT THE DANGERS TO OUR COUNTRY
CAN COME NOT ONLY ACROSS BORDERS
BUT FROM VIOLENCE THAT GATHERS
WITHIN.
THERE IS LITERAL CULTURAL
OVERLAP BETWEEN VIOLENT
EXTREMISTS ARE BROAD AND VIOLENT
EXTREMISTS A HOME, BUT IN THEIR
DISREGARD FOR HUMAN LIFE, AND
THEIR DETERMINATION, THEY ARE
CHILDREN OF THE SAME FOUL SPIRIT
AND IT IS OUR CONTINUING DUTY TO
CONFRONT THEM.
>> Laura: OF COURSE, BUSHES
AND TALKING ABOUT CONFRONTING
THE FOUL SPIRIT OF ANTIFA OR
BLM.
REMEMBER, THEIR RAMPAGES AND
RIOTS CAUSED DEATH AND
DESTRUCTION COAST-TO-COAST.
DO YOU REMEMBER PRESIDENT BUSH
SPEAKING OUT ABOUT ANY OF THAT?
DID HE EVER RAISE AN OBJECTION
IF THEY KNOW IT'S NOT?
WHEN HE TRIED TO BIRD DOWN
ST. JOHN'S CHURCH ACROSS FROM
THE WHITE HOUSE, DID
PRESIDENT BUSH DECRY THE
DEFILING OF THAT NATIONAL
SYMBOL?
NO AND NO.
WHOEVER WROTE THOSE REMARKS FOR
BUSH THIS WEEKEND AND OF COURSE
THEY WERE WRITTEN FOR HIM ALSO
IN EFFECT WROTE THEM FOR BIDEN
AND FORMER PRESIDENT OBAMA AND
CLINTON AS WELL.
ON THE 20TH ANNIVERSARY OF THE
9/11 ATTACKS, HOW CYNICALLY
CLEVER OF THE DEMOCRATS WHEN
BIDEN IS ON THE ROPES TO HAVE A
FORMER REPUBLICAN PRESIDENT/ART
TRUMP AND HIS SUPPORTERS.
OF COURSE, THE ELITES WHO
DESPISE BUSH FOR THE EIGHT YEARS
HE WAS IN OFFICE LEFT IT ALL UP.
>> THIS WILL NOW BE BUILT INTO
HIS LEGACY.
IT IS STANDING UP AND SAYING
THINGS LIKE THAT ABOUT TRUTH AND
ABOUT WHAT IS REAL AND RIGHT AND
FACTUAL.
>> CHILDREN OF THE SAME FOUL
SPIRIT IS A STRIKING LINE FROM
GEORGE W. BUSH.
THIS IS THE BIGGEST PLATFORM HE
WILL HAVE FOR THE YEAR MAY BE
SEVERAL YEARS.
>> FELT LIKE HE NEEDED TO SEND A
MORAL MESSAGE.
ALSO LIFTING PEOPLE UP IN AN
EMOTIONAL WAY ALSO.
>> WERE NEEDED BEFORE AN HITTING
TRUNK, ONE DAY IN OCTOBER 2017,
BOTH MEN AND SEPARATES SPEECHES
HIT TRUMP WITHOUT MENTIONING HIM
BY NAME AND WHEN BENGHAZI WENT
DOWN, REMEMBER BUSH DID NOT
SPEAK OUT.
WITHOUT A SINGLE REPUBLICAN
VOTE, BUSH DID NOT SPEAK OUT.
WHEN BIDEN CREATED A
HUMANITARIAN NATIONAL SECURITY
AND ECONOMIC NIGHTMARE THE
SOUTHERN BORDER, OF COURSE BUSH
DID NOT SPEAK OUT.
BUT WHEN DONALD TRUMP BEGAN TO
SLOWLY BUT SURELY CALLED OUT AND
BUSHES GLOBALIST LEGACY, BUSH
COULDN'T STOP HIMSELF.
THEN IT BECAME PERSONAL.
>> BIGOTRY SEEMS EMBOLDENED.
POLITICS SEEM MORE VULNERABLE TO
CONSPIRACY THEORIES AND OUTRIGHT
FABRICATION.
WE'VE SEEN NATIONALISM DISTORTED
INTO NATIVISM.
WE SEE A FADING CONFIDENCE IN
THE VALUE OF FREE MARKETS AND
INTERNATIONAL TRADE.
WE'VE SEEN THE RETURN OF
ISOLATION SENTIMENTS AND IN ALL
THESE WAYS, WE NEED TO RECALL
AND RECOVER OUR OWN IDENTITY.
>> Laura: HAVE EXACTLY WHERE
THAT BE ANY DIFFERENT FROM WHAT
ANY PROMINENT DEMOCRAT WOULD
HAVE SAID THEN ABOUT TRUMP?
FOR BUSH, IT WAS ONLY WORTH
SPEAKING OUT TO DEFEND HIS OWN
LEGACY, NEVER TO STAND UP FOR
TRUE CONSERVATISM.
AMIDST THE AVALANCHE OF PRAISE
FOR HIS SATURDAY REMARKS, LET'S
NOT FORGET THAT AFTER SEVEN
YEARS OF WAR, THE LOSS OF NEARLY
5 MILLION MANUFACTURING JOBS
OVERSEAS -- MORE THAN THAT,
ACTUALLY, AND THE 2008 FINANCIAL
CRISIS, BUSH'S APPROVAL RATING
WAS IN THE HIGH 20s AT THE END
OF HIS LAST FULL YEAR IN OFFICE.
REPUBLICANS UNDER BUSH LOST THE
HOUSE, LOST THE SENATE, AND
JOHN McCAIN WHO DOUBLED DOWN
ON BUSH'S RECORD GOT SHELLACKED
BY BARACK OBAMA IN 2008.
TURNS OUT G.O.P. VOTERS HAVE HAD
ENOUGH, THE COUNTRY HAD HAD
ENOUGH.
AND NOW AFTER THEY LOST THEIR
GRIP ON THE G.O.P. FOR GOOD, THE
OLD BUSH ESTABLISHMENT ARE OLDER
BUT NOT WISER.
BUSH'S REMARKS SET THE STAGE TO
BOOST BIDEN AND THE DEMOCRATS.
THEY ARE FLAILING WITH THEIR
AGENDA NOW AND POISED FOR A
WIPEOUT IN 2022 BUT BUSH CAME IN
TO TRY TO DO A TEMPORARY SAVE.
AND ALL THE MEDIA CAN DO IS
ATTACK REPUBLICANS AS RACIST,
WHITE SUPREMACIST, AND
INSURRECTIONIST.
THE ENTIRE THING IS PATHETIC AND
MOST OF ALL, IT'S REVEALING.
IT SHOWS THAT THEY KNOW THEIR
AGENDA IS DELIVERING DESPAIR AND
WILL NOT IMPROVE THE LIVES OF
AVERAGE AMERICANS.
>> IT'S NOT JUST SAD, IT'S
DANGEROUS THAT WE ARE IN A
SITUATION WHERE WE NEED DEFENSE.
>> INCREDIBLY DAMAGING ATTACK,
THE SEEDS OF THAT STILL
CONTINUE.
>> THAT'S THE EFFECTIVENESS OF
TERRORISM THAT YOU'VE GOT TO
ALWAYS BE PREPARED BECAUSE YOU
DON'T KNOW WITH THIS GROUP NOW
COULD TURN TO A TERRORIST
ATTACK.
>> OF COURSE, THEY ARE TALKING
ABOUT THIS RALLY NEXT SATURDAY
THAT NO ONE I KNOW HAS EVER
HEARD OF.
THEIR VIEW AND BUSH'S VIEW IS
THAT SINCE THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
HAS NO LONGER FOLLOW THE BUSHES,
IT SHOULD BE LABELED AS A TERROR
ORGANIZATION.
THIS IDEA IS BEING OPENLY
DISCUSSED AMONG THE LEFT.
LET'S NOT KID OURSELVES, THE
BUSHES HELP TO RAISE HUNDRED
$50 MILLION FOR THE 2016 RUN IN
THE END, JEB DROPPED OUT BEFORE
GETTING TO HIS OWN HOME STATE
PRIMARY.
AND THEY STILL DON'T GET IT.
THEY'RE NOT MAD AT THE PEOPLE
WHO CALLED HIM A WAR CRIMINAL OR
HITLER OR RIDICULES HIM EVERY
WEEK ON "SNL," THE BUSHES ARE
MET AT THE REPUBLICANS WHO
REJECTED THEIR POLICIES.
THEY ALL CLAIM THAT TRUMP WAS
THE DEVIL INCARNATE FOR
DEMANDING LOYALTY FOR THE PEOPLE
WHO WORK FOR THEM BUT THE TRUTH
IS, THE BUSHES WERE THE ONES WHO
DEMANDED PERSONAL LOYALTY
REGARDLESS OF HOW THEIR POLICIES
AFFECTED THE COUNTRY.
THIS IS ALL HARD FOR ME TO SAY
ACTUALLY BECAUSE I ALWAYS LIKED
THE BUSHES PERSONALLY.
BUT WHAT I QUESTIONED AND
ULTIMATELY HELP TO TORPEDO THE
QUALIFICATION TO THE
SUPREME COURT, THE BUSH
WHITE HOUSE MADE IT CLEAR THEY
WOULDN'T EVER DEAL WITH ME
AGAIN.
YOU CAN NEVER GO AGAINST THE
FAMILY.
SO THE OLD BUSH GUARD HAS
DECLARED AN UNWINNABLE WAR AGAIN
AND THIS TIME, IT'S AGAINST THE
74 MILLION PLUS REPUBLICANS WHO
VOTED FOR TRUMP IN 2020 AND WHO
DIDN'T VOTE FOR JEB BUSH IN
2016.
I'M SURE THEY HOPE THAT THE
LEFTIST HISTORIANS WILL TREAT
THEM MORE KINDLY IN THE FUTURE
THAN THEY HAVE IN THE PAST.
MAYBE THEY WILL, BUT I DOUBT IT.
SO WHILE BUSH WAS TRYING TO
APPEAL TO THAT VERY MEDIA THAT
HAS DEMONIZED HIM FOR YEARS,
HERE'S WHAT TRUMP IS DOING.
>> I'M DOING OKAY.
I DON'T HAVE THAT MANY.
>> YOU ARE NEW YORK'S FINEST,
INCREDIBLE PEOPLE.
>> I LOVE YOU.
>> Laura: THAT'S KIND OF WHAT
HAPPENED TO THE G.O.P., IT FOUND
ITS REAL BASS AGAIN.
THE FACT IS, MOST CONSERVATIVES
WANT TO SHAKE OFF THE WILL THE
THE ALLURE OF THE BUSHES.
EXCITING YOUNG GOVERNORS WHO